if a girl gets like sleeps with a ton of  people there's [ __ ] shaming and so like  they take away the things that men care  about but they don't do that to women  like like even so if we if we get fat  we're bailed out of that decision  because there's body positivity if we  sleep around we're bailed out of that  decision so if we if we decide to be  [ __ ] we're bailed out because there's  birth control if that fails we're bailed  out because of abortion if that fails  and you keep the kid and you're homeless  you're bailed out because there's women  in children's centers if if that doesn't  work there's some government program and  here I'm not I'm not sure what it is but  there's always some government program  paying out single mothers so it's like  whatever we do we're bailed out